relleno la tabla con números enteros
para escribir 22 de tres formas
diferentes aquí tenemos las decenas y
las unidades en las decenas vamos a
poner un 2 y en las unidades otro 2 dos
decenas 20 2 unidades ahora aquí vamos a
poner una decena y en las unidades vamos
a poner 12 unidades aquí en la tercera
opción vamos a poner 0 decenas y vamos a
poner 22 unidades
vamos a ver nuestra respuesta estuvo muy
bien vamos a hacer otro ejercicio lleva
los espacios para completar la ecuación
tenemos 94 mil 39 decenas de millas tres
millares más un espacio en blanco de
centenas más tres decenas tenemos
nuestras tres decenas no hay unidades
hasta aquí vemos bien aquí no tenemos
centenas pero aquí en millares nos dicen
que son tres millares y aquí tenemos
cuatro millares cuatro mil así que
quitaron un millar de acá y seguramente
lo pusieron aquí en las centenas así que
vamos a poner diez centenas que es un
millar
y ahora si tenemos todos los elementos
necesarios vamos a comprobar la
respuesta muy bien estuvo bien vamos a
hacer otro ejercicio
ahora rellena la tabla con los números
enteros para escribir 210 de tres formas
diferentes centenas y decenas pues vamos
a poner dos centenas doscientos y una
decena que son diez
otra forma es poner una centena y
reacomodarlo dentro de las decenas y nos
queda 11 decenas la última opción es
poner cero en las centenas y poner aquí
veintiuno de cero es comprobar respuesta
muy bien creo que con esto ya tenemos un
mejor entendimiento de lo que es la
reagrupación de los números enteros o
los números completos nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo